five nights at freddys ah hello my face
is in the corner is this another one by
Caspi oh I see oh oh no [ __ ] this is
actually fine okay we're okay okay it's
a door to leave totally Phil this is
nuts
you actually made five nights at
Freddy's in happy wheels Oh
how do you even do that that's amazing
baby got you baby
nice boy whoa Oh God
no joke no joke and this one's gone oh
hang on wait a minute Oh
oh that don't look good muffin
holy cow
oh this is different
Oh Margaret
Marga by our impost the Arab oil I'm not
we're Mario buyer cannot win
oh okay oh okay there's pretty much
nothing
Magua jetwash you believe anything oh
come on Jim you should've believed order
pendulum won't get me whoa
I like the gentle rubber you did across
my nose market my right whoa whoa Tim
easy there whoa control your rage okay
Tim just calm your uncontrollable rage
is strength if I said you took that
growth theorem you've been all out of
breath didn't Bieber that's me I'm gonna
kill him
okay oh it's Christmas it's not even
Halloween yet got time for me to come
out of my cave okay Wow
Marla Wynne Marga bar think fast
well okay then oh my arms I'm still how
am I doing this
what am i doing where am I going
not one market are mine fall a well all
oh [ __ ] this okay
well I'm doing poorly already well
you're a god this is probably whoa I
think you're down there okay well then
I'll just okay yeah you go off through
that body part yeah I did wrong okay I'm
in trouble
alright you sly devil let's see how you
deal with my technics okay that was
surprising I thought I was gonna die but
somehow I'm still alive
hello oh good boy oh my god I'm a
delicate ballerina nothing could stop me
now okay I gotta escape at the box how
can I let me I'm innocent I tell ya I'm
innocent
hey I'll tell you I do essential oh well
that looks like Oh oh thank you kind sir
for allowing me twist how markiplier
neck test okay when will this nightmare
end okay then this is almost beautiful
my god this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks to
get everyone and as always I will see
in the next video by